Chris the dominant story of the day the
Russell Wilson contract getting his
money from the Seattle Seahawks set that
deadline it worked he has a five-year
157 million dollar deal and last Friday
big cat and I debated whether or not
Russell Wilson should be the first guy
that a team says no thanks to as it
relates to paying that market setting
money to a franchise quarterback clearly
Russell Wilson wasn't is there a guy out
there you're thinking of it could be the
first one because at some point it feels
like one of these teams is gonna say
we're getting off of this treadmill
we're not gonna put all this money into
one player we can't afford to do it and
have a competitive team so no we refuse
to pay a franchise quarterback market
value money do you think there's a team
out there that would do it I mean I'm
hoping there is I feel like you know
again I know I've said this you know a
few times over the last week but the
proof is in the pudding in recent
history you know with teams with
quarterback friendly deals being in the
Super Bowl or the Final Four or whatever
you want to talk about I mean this year
is a perfect simple first of all New
England all years Brady has a
quarterback friendly deal their roster
is complete it's got great depth you
know Patrick mahomes was in the AFC
Championship game rookie deal Jared Goff
of the Super Bowl rookie deal the
Philadelphia Eagles won in the Super
Bowl last year rookie deal with Carson
Wentz and Nick falls being paid as a
backup you know also that year Blake
bortles Case Keenum
not making huge money they were in the
Final Four you know the all the years
the Seattle Seahawks with Russell Wilson
the two years they were in the Super
Bowl you know what else am I missing
the Ravens 49ers match or a matchup
Kaepernick verse Flacco they were
unlucky deals so when will a team have
the guts to do it
I don't know I mean you know who we
gonna say is Marcus Mariota I don't
think he's gonna get a big franchise
deal unless he just absolutely blows us
out of the water this year so there's
you see a franchise for Melo that's
right that's where I'm like so where do
we draw the line here no I think the
guys that we know are franchise
quarterbacks it won't happen to I guess
is what I'm saying but those guys that
are on the fringe I think we are getting
towards the time where
you're gonna go you know what let's move
on we don't need to have a fringe
franchise guy taking up 20% of our
salary cap we saw Washington do it with
Kirk Cousins after paying him 20 million
under the franchise tag one year and 24
million the next year that's when they
finally decided to cut the cord on
cousins and they've been you know
well if Alec Smith doesn't get injured
the quarterback position is taken care
of but more recently they've been
floating around trying to figure out
what they're going to do but I think
about Jared Goff yeah look regardless of
what you think of Jared Goff as a player
is he really good enough to merit the
kind of gigantic investment that he may
want especially when you consider that
Sean McVeigh the coach of the Rams could
find another quarterback and be more
likely to coach him up into a great
player it's one thing for Pete Carril a
defensive coach to bail on Russell
Wilson and try to groom a young
quarterback McVeigh can do it in his
sleep and whether it's Kirk Cousins who
will be available after two years or
whoever else may be out there I could
see Sean McVeigh having the confidence
that he could get another guy to play at
the same level that we have seen Jared
Goff play I mean you think about the
team that McVeigh inherited he took a
bunch of guys he didn't pick that
weren't his guys you know Jeff Fisher
guys and he's made them into a great
offense maybe he could do that much
better and more effectively with guys
that he had a clear input in bringing to
the team in the first place and maybe
that's what he would like to do deep
down at the quarterback position and
maybe Jared Goff will demand so much
that it makes it easier for McVeigh to
say we're just gonna go this rookie or
or you know different veteran route
rather than paying Jared Goff big money
yeah he was certainly one name that came
to my mind yes because Jared Goff again
you know he's the number one pick I know
they went to the Super Bowl and all that
he's in the top half of football and
quarterbacks but he's not in the top ten
you know he's somewhere between 10 and
16 I would say if I just had a roughly
list the quarterbacks yeah and do you
really want to break the bank but the
other element to that is you know of
course the fan base is gonna look at
Jared Goff and go well since he's been
our quarterback we've turned things
around and there's gonna be that public
pressure and kind of perception out
there
let alone he's also a Southern
California kid which I think even adds
to the pressure more when you play for a
team in Southern California to begin
with so I you know I don't know I don't
know if the Rams will have the guts when
all said and done but I really can't
wait for a team to have the guts and
make this type of move well but the
thing is you know it's our guts in their
blood because if you do make that move
and you go all-in with a young guy you
put a ton of pressure on him and you put
your job on the line if you let that
franchise quarterback walk away and your
franchise disintegrates without it yeah
you're gonna hear a lot of my goals or
so yeah right and and you're gonna hear
a lot of i-told-you-so and you're gonna
hear you're fired eventually from the
owner of your team because chances are
the owner you know owners are
notoriously conservative in the NFL and
I'm not talking about politically I'm
talking about doing the safe thing the
safe thing is keeping that franchise
quarterback that all these other teams
are desperate to find you have one you
find a way to keep that guy
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports